[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und christian sievers
sie nahmen den 1 der krieg hat uns
längst erreicht dessen folgen spüren wir
auch in deutschland und so wie es
aussieht ist das erst der anfang der
bundeswirtschaftsminister wirft russland
einen ökonomischen angriff vor mit
energie als waffe energie aus russland
von der wir nach wie vor enorme maß
abhängig sind deren preis in enorme maß
steigt so dass der herrscher im kreml
auch wenn die lieferungen sinken dennoch
kräftig kasse gemacht und auch eine
weitere entwicklung dürfte ganz im sinn
von wladimir putin sein die
bundesregierung fürchtet zunehmend
soziale und politische verwerfungen
sprengstoff nennt das der kanzler heute
und der bundespräsident mahnt dringend
mehr staatliche hilfe an wir beginnen
heute abend mit patricia wiedemeier das
erste berlin direkt sommerinterview
findet im hamburger hafen statt an einem
ort der für welthandel steht doch genau
der ist derzeit bedroht unter anderem
durch den krieg in der ukraine
und so ist es wohl keine überraschung
dass es in dem gespräch mit dem
bundespräsidenten vor allem um die
folgen des krieges geht steinmeier lobt
die bisherigen entlastungsmaßnahmen
fordert aber eine gerechtere verteilung
die pakete die es bisher gegeben hat
waren gut und war notwendig haben sogar
dazu beigetragen dass die inflation
wenigstens etwas gebrochen wurde aber
man wird die situation weiter im auge
haben und instrumente überlegen müssen
wie man insbesondere den
geringverdienern wie man denen das leben
erleichtert man habe bereits viel getan
so der kanzler heute im sommerinterview
bei der ard für insgesamt 30 milliarden
habe man zum beispiel den
grundfreibetrag erhöht eine
heizkostenpauschale und das neun euro
ticket eingeführt für dieses jahr sagen
fast alle die nach gerechnet haben dass
wir bei den unteren und mittleren
einkommen ungefähr 90 prozent der
preissteigerung durch die vielen
maßnahmen die wir ergriffen haben
aufgefangen haben im fokus stehe es nun
vor allem die hohen heizkosten
abzufedern und verändert das ist
sozialer sprengstoff darüber muss man
ganz klar
ihre worte finden aber es reicht ja
nicht worte zu finden wir müssen das
eine tun nämlich alles was möglich ist
damit die energieversorgung weiter
funktioniert sozialer sprengstoff wer
die gaslieferungen aus russland gestoppt
werden davor warnt auch der
bundeswirtschaftsminister
wenn wir es nicht schaffen die speicher
voll zu haben und nicht
reservekapazitäten über andere wege in
einem gewissen umfang nach deutschland
zu holen
glaube ich werden wir sehr sehr
gespannte angespannte gereizt debatten
zu führen haben einen energiepreis
deckel für privathaushalte fordert daher
die dgb-vorsitzende fach chemie zitat
für jeden erwachsenen und jedes kind
wird ein grundbedarf für strom und gas
festgelegt für diese menge an
kilowattstunden gibt es eine
preisgarantie für energie die jemand
darüber hinaus verbraucht muss er mehr
zahlen beide kanzler und präsident
warnen vor schweren zeiten bevorstehen
steinmeier spricht von einem
epochenbruch dem putin verursacht habe
das ist jetzt ein bruch mit der
normalität es kann auch sein dass wir
mehrere harte jahre vor uns haben aber
wir sind mit unseren möglichkeiten mit
einer starken wirtschaft mit einer
vernetzung in der welt sind wir besser
aufgestellt als viele andere ein
bundespräsident der versucht am ende
etwas zuversicht zu demonstrieren
doch auch diese starke wirtschaft könnte
in schwierigkeiten geraten wenn das gas
aus russland ausbleibt
kerstin andreae ist
hauptgeschäftsführerin des
bundesverbands der energie und
wasserwirtschaft sie vertritt über 1.900
überregionale energieversorger und
kommunale stadtwerke in deutschland und
sie macht sich große sorgen frau andrea
guten abend könnten sie das was ist denn
das szenario dass sie nicht mehr
schlafen lässt naja wir erleben ja seit
längerem dass aus russland weniger gas
fließt durch die leitungen und jetzt
beginnt eben die revision von nord
stream 1 dass sie normalerweise zwei
wochen wo auch tatsächlich kein gas nach
deutschland geflossen ist aber in diesen
zwei wochen haben wir aus den
gasspeichern gas genommen und jetzt
gerade sind wir der situation dass wir
eigentlich dadurch dass schon so wenig
gas aus russland kommt mehr in die
speicher geben müssten das heißt unterm
strich machen wir uns sorgen ob im
winter genügend gas vorhanden ist und
dann gibt es eine erhebliche
wirtschaftliche schieflage die da droht
der größte deutsche gasimporteur juniper
vor dem wiederum auch viele stadtwerke
kaufen ist in not weil er sich gas
besorgen muss zu preisen für die er das
gas aktuell nicht verkaufen kann weil er
längerfristige verträge gelten wie groß
ist denn die gefahr dass auch stadtwerke
kippen
also es ist absolut richtig dass die
bundesregierung ganz vorne in der
lieferkette ansetzt und die importeure
also in dem fall juniper auch versucht
zu stützen und zu unterstützen damit es
dieses teure gas auch finanzieren kann
und die kette besteht im prinzip aus dem
importeur aus den versorgern in dem fall
jetzt die genannten stadtwerke aber auch
andere unternehmen und am schluss die
endkunden die wirtschaft die menschen
wie sie und ich und die sorge ist dass
es einen dominoeffekt gibt das also
einer die preise weitergeben muss die
hohen die am markt dann hat bezahlen
müssen dieser die dann wiederum
weitergibt und wir so in einen
kaskadeneffekt kommen wo irgendwann
einer strauchelt und deswegen ist es so
wichtig dass in dieser lieferkette
wirklich alle im blick genommen werden
weil versorgung der menschen versorgung
mit energie ist eben ein sehr sehr
wichtiger moment und da tut die
bundesregierung gut daran die
instrumente zu prüfen ok auf diese
instrumente kommen wir gleich noch ja
erst noch eine zwischenfrage der
bundeswirtschaftsminister sagt bei
einigen stadtwerken könne es zu einer
preis explosion kommen heißt dass manche
haben besser aufgepasst als andere die
stadtwerke haben sehr unterschiedliche
verträge das kommt dann im einzelnen
drauf an wer sich kurzfristiger wer sich
langfristiger wer auf welcher
preisorientierung gas beschafft hat
mittelfristig werden wir bei den hohen
gaspreisen aber sehen dass
wesentlich stadtwerke und versorger in
bedrängnis geraten weil die preise eben
hoch sind und absehbar hoch bleiben
irgendwann sind die auch langfristigen
verträge ausgelaufen und dann gilt es
alle in den blick zu nehmen ok alle in
den blick nehmen da gibt es eine reihe
von ideen was zu tun ist alle den blick
nehmen dh der übersetzt dass die kunden
mehr zahlen sollen und das ist all
diesen ideen auch gemein fangen wir
vielleicht mal mit der sogenannten
preisanpassungsklausel an das bedeutet
also kurzfristig kosten auf kunden
abwälzen sich also quasi aus der
vertraglichen absprache befreien manche
sagen schon das würde eine prozesslawine
nach sich ziehen was sagen sie dazu
also der grundgedanke ist richtig der
grundgedanke lautet wenn sich der
versorger aufgrund dieser jetzt
kriegssituationen und den nicht mehr
liefern liefersituation aus russland
über neue ersatzbeschaffung gas besorgen
muss und das ist enorm teuer dann kann
der versorger auf diesen kosten nicht
hängen bleiben sonst geht der binnen
kurzer frist in die knie und das wollen
wir nicht das können wir auch nicht
wollen deswegen ist es wichtig die
versorger zu stützen und das die die
preise weitergeben können aber liegt
natürlich der hase im pfeffer wenn die
wir preise jetzt so weitergegeben werden
dann sind ja die nächsten unter druck
nämlich die kunden die endverbraucher
die wirtschaft die industrie und das ist
dieser kaskadeneffekt er eben am ende
bei den menschen auch ankommt und da
muss die bundesregierung handeln
einfach ein preisschild dran zu machen
das ist jetzt die rede von
2800 euro im jahr gaspreise für einen
durchschnittshaushalt ist das ungefähr
die preisklasse mit der wieder aktuell
rechnen müssten also es ist wahnsinnig
schwierig im moment kalkulationen oder
prognosen abzugeben für die
preisentwicklung aber sicher ist sie
gehen nach oben gas bleibt teuer energie
bleibt teuer hier insbesondere eben das
gas was wir jetzt hier sehen können und
deswegen ist davon auszugehen dass es
die haushalte stark belastet dann gibt
es diese idee ein neues umlageverfahren
einzuführen das dann quasi sämtliche gas
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher treffen
würde aber jeden einzelnen
möglicherweise nicht mehr ganz so hart
wie konkret stellen sie sich das vor
das umlageverfahren ist wie sie sagen so
eine art solidaris muss über alle und es
hat einen ganz großen vorteil sie können
das umlageverfahren oder die umlage
zeitlich strecken also man könnte
entscheiden dass nicht alles sofort bei
allen ankommt sondern dass wir über die
jahre
diese umlage strecken in natürlich der
voraussicht dass die situation sich auch
verbessert dafür müssen wir viel tun
aber das ist der große vorteil der
umlage sie würde nicht so hart treffen
dauerhaft und das ist ganz klar hilft
nur die abhängigkeit von russischer
energie beenden komplett beenden und auf
erneuerbare setzen wie schnell kann denn
das jetzt ganz konkret aus ihrer sicht
gehen das muss schnell gehen das muss
auch deswegen schnell gehen weil wir was
die klimaziele angeht und das oster
paket was die bundesregierung jetzt
verabschiedet hat das ziel haben dass
wir 80 prozent unseres stroms im jahr
2030 aus erneuerbaren haben wollen das
heißt jetzt muss es wirklich ein turbo
gebend für wind an land für pv für solar
für wind offshore für biomasse da steckt
viel potenzial und das ist auch der weg
in den wir gehen müssen sagt kerstin
andreae sie ist hauptgeschäftsführerin
des bundesverbandes der energie und
wasserwirtschaft ich danke ihnen
herzlich ich danke ihnen und
das gespräch aber aus termingründen von
einer knappen stunde aufgezeichnet ein
neuer weg also erneuerbare energien
statt abhängigkeit von einem kriegsherrn
problem es dauert und in deutschland
zumindest so wie sich dieses land bisher
zeigt dauert es besonders lang deshalb
geht die bundesregierung aktuell quasi
wieder zurück um irgendwie nach vorne zu
kommen und entdeckt die kohle neu die
gute alte kann man ja nicht sagen denn
eigentlich wollten sie so schnell wie
möglich loswerden was das alles konkret
bedeutet vor ort wo die kohle liegt
zeigt nicola albrecht jetzt aus
brandenburg das kohlekraftwerk in
jänschwalde brandenburg längst sind nur
noch vier von sechs kraftwerksblöcken in
betrieb sukzessive runterfahren die
devise der ausstieg aus der kohle bis
spätestens 2008 und 30 galt als fest
vereinbart doch nun heißt es nicht nur
hier
kehrtwende alles wieder hochfahren und
energie für deutschland liefern denn nur
kohle könne kurzfristig erdgas in der
stromerzeugung ersetzen darin sind sich
experten einig
das ist eine sinnvolle maßnahme alles
hat irgendwo seinen preis wir könnten
das auch nicht machen und am kohle
ausstieg festhalten dann haben wir
wirklich eine gasmenge lage im winter
und die ist jetzt schon sichtbar
erdgaskraftwerke die nur strom erzeugen
können sehr sehr gut durch braunkohle
und steinkohle kraftwerke ersetzt werden
allerdings fließt gerade mal 17 prozent
des erdgasverbrauchs in die
stromerzeugung einen löwenanteil
kompensiert die kohle also nicht und so
beugt man sich in brandenburgs revier
auch nur zähneknirschend im kraftwerk
brauchen sie nun mehr personal für den
winter als vorhanden der tagebau
jänschwalde sollte eigentlich 2023
seinen betrieb einstellen und überhaupt
hatte man hart um den ausstieg gerungen
nun ist sie da die sorge vor
rückschlägen das heißt natürlich auf der
einen seite erst mal eine wahnsinnige
kraftanstrengung die leute müssen noch
mal ihr ganzes potenzial da rein
strecken zu sagen wir müssen jetzt mehr
kohle abbauen wir wollen das zur
versorgungssicherheit auch leisten aber
es hängt uns auch in der frage der
zukunft und dem schnelleren vorankommen
im strukturwandel zum strukturwandel
gehört auch der ausbau von co2 freien
energieerzeugern und dafür kämpft sie
schon lange rebecca schwarzbach hat
naturschutz in brandenburg studiert
kennt die folgen des kohleabbaus für die
umwelt das erneute hochfahren sieht sie
kritisch dass der betreiber der
kraftwerke und tagebaue zudem fordert
nun die emissionsgrenzen nicht mehr
einhalten zu müssen für sie inakzeptabel
das wird für die weiteren jahre viele
millionen tonnen co2 verursachen und
damit die klimakatastrophe weiter
vorantreiben und die auswirkungen sehen
wir schon hier mit großem dürreperioden
mit viel mehr wind und sturm
extremwetterereignissen klimaforscher
widersprechen nicht kohle ist ein
klimakiller aber ihre temporäre
renaissance eine vertretbare notlösung
in einer notlage der effekt auf das
klima ist nicht groß solange das einfach
vorübergehend weil also ein
kurzfristiger anstieg von emissionen ja
die globale mitteltemperatur nicht
ansteigen lässt und dann sind sie sich
in brandenburg ausnahmsweise mal fast
alle einig dass nun vor allem eins
passieren müsse tempo beim ausbau
erneuerbarer energien
vor einer knappen stunde in kopenhagen
die dänische polizei bestätigt die
befürchtungen aus dem frühen abend ja es
hat mehrere todesopfer gegeben und
mehrere verletzte nach schüssen in einem
großen einkaufszentrum in kopenhagen die
polizei schließt nicht aus dass die tat
einen terroristischen hintergrund hat
mehr von dominik löschmeister es ist
gegen nachmittag augenzeugen berichten
von chaotischen szenen in einem
einkaufszentrum in kopenhagen wird
geschossen menschen seien dabei von
kugeln getroffen worden nach neuesten
angaben der dänischen polizei wurden
auch mehrere menschen getötet
was wir bis jetzt wissen ist dass die
kopenhagener polizei heute abend
ungefähr um 17.30 benachrichtigt wurde
das im fields einkaufszentrum geschossen
wird wir rückten sofort mit massiven
kräften aus und stellten fest dass dort
geschossen wurde wir wissen jetzt dass
auch mehrere menschen getötet wurden als
wir dort ankamen stellen wir einen
verdächtigen in unmittelbarer nähe er
sitzt jetzt in haft und wir versuchen
mehr herauszubekommen
bei dem mutmaßlichen täter handelt es
sich um einen 22 jahre alten dänischen
man es gebe keine hinweise darauf dass
noch weitere schützen vor ort gewesen
sein diese mutter berichtet von einem
telefonat mit ihrer tochter sie rief
mich an und sagte mama sie schießen und
sie weinte und war sehr aufgebracht und
sagte mir ihre freundin sei mit mehreren
anderen in der toilette eingesperrt und
sie hätten angst heraus zu kommen sie
ist jetzt draußen will aber nicht ohne
ihre freundin gehen die polizei in
kopenhagen geht bisher davon aus dass
der mutmaßliche täter alleine gehandelt
hat
einen terroristischen hintergrund
schließt man nicht aus
und soeben kommt die nachricht dass dein
harrys teils konzert abgesagt wurde in
einer konzerthalle in unmittelbarer nähe
des tatorts da waren eigentlich noch
besucherinnen und besucher eingelassen
worden denen hat die polizei jetzt
gesagt sie sollen ruhig nach hause gehen
wir halten sie weiter informiert aber
jetzt erst mal den überblick über diesen
nachrichten sonntag weitere wichtige
nachrichten von dir gundula da zunächst
zum russischen krieg gegen die ukraine
nach wochenlangen kämpfen zieht sich die
ukrainische armee aus der stadt ließ sie
ganz im osten des landes zurück die
russischen besatzungstruppen hätten eine
mehrfache überlegenheit
lang war die letzte größere bastion der
ukraine im gebiet lugansk die eroberung
gehört zu den von russland benannten
vorrangigen ziel zielen des krieges nach
wie vor ungeklärt ist der beschluss
einer russischen grenzstadt dabei wurden
vier menschen getötet
bei einem gletscherabbruch in den
italienischen dolomiten sind mindestens
sechs menschen ums leben gekommen acht
weitere wurden zum teil schwer verletzt
das unglück ereignete sich am marie
murata bergmassiv eine lawine aus schnee
eis und fels hatte sich gelöst auf dem
gipfel waren zuletzt ungewöhnlich hohe
temperaturen gemessen worden zur
nationalität der verunglückten
bergsteiger ist noch nichts bekannt
nach schweren regenfällen an der
ostküste australiens müssen tausende
einwohner von sydney ihre häuser wegen
hochwasserwarnungen verlassen
außenbezirke der stadt sind bereits
überflutet der baraka madame für die
trinkwasserversorgung von sydney ist
übergelaufen experten warnen vor
weiteren sintflutartigen regenfällen in
der region habe es schon jetzt viermal
so viel geregnet wie sonst im gesamten
juli
der fachkräftemangel in deutschland
belastet auch das handwerk
150.000 offene stellen gebe es da sagt
der zentralverband des deutschen
handwerks
und da nicht alle betriebe diese melden
sei von bis zu
250.000 fehlenden handwerkerinnen und
handwerkern auszugehen auch gefährde er
ist die umsetzung der energiewende wenn
es nicht genügend fachkräfte für den
ausbau der erneuerbaren gebe
in köln haben mehr als eine million
menschen den christopher street day
gefeiert und dabei für toleranz und
vielfalt demonstriert ihre forderung
gleiche rechte für homosexuelle menschen
sowie für bi trans und intersexuelle und
queren
180 musikwagen beteiligten sich an der
parade als erster
nordrhein-westfälischer
ministerpräsident
eröffnete hendrik wüst dem csd köln
setzte damit ein starkes zeichen gegen
hass und ausgrenzung
es sind nur ein paar seiten mit einem
foto drin bei manchen ist der wein rot
bei anderen tiefblau die belgier drucken
neuerdings ihre comic helden hinein aber
spätestens wenn man damit an einem
grenzübergang steht und mitbekommt wie
die einen drangsaliert und die anderen
durchgewunken werden wird klar so ein
pass hat es in sich eröffnet
möglichkeiten und er kann
machtinstrument sein und sogar waffe
eine faszinierende neue ausstellung in
berlin zeigt die entstehung und
entwicklung der staatsbürgerschaft
anhand eines unscheinbaren stücks papier
dabei kann sie weit zurück gucken und
doch ganz aktuell bleiben david guetta
hat
es ist eine leise waffe aus papier die
die ukraine schleichen trifft schaaf
gestellt per stempel verteilt von
russischen besatzern in eroberten
gebieten putins pass krieg im schatten
der geschütze hinter der front
das ziel dahinter ist eine ethnische
entmischung dieser gebiete die
irgendwann russisch und riskiert sein
sollen so wirkt der pass als waffe als
eine mildere waffe als die sozusagen
gewaltsamen einsätze einsatz von von
raketen und panzern aber dennoch
wirksamer und teilweise auch länger weil
er mit realitäten spiel qualitäten
untergräbt und sie spaltet eine neue
sonderausstellung über
staatsbürgerschaften im deutschen
historischen museum berlin zeigt
vorläufer imperialer landnahme mit dem
pass als waffe etwa sogenannte
germanisierung maßnahmen der
nationalsozialisten im besetzten polen
aber die waffe kann sich auch nach innen
richten als pass entzug wenn als
volksverräter diffamierte an den pranger
gestellt und aus der staatsbürgerschaft
ausgestoßen wurden oder in der ddr
oppositionelle unbequeme liedermacher
offiziell ausgebürgert man will
so gar keine gehirn es waren nobody ist
man frei wild es kann man von jedem hoya
geschützt werden das ringen um
staatsbürgerliche emanzipation ohne
wurzeln zu verleugnen es ist
jahrhunderte alt und immer wieder
aktuell wer gehört dazu nun ist die
ampel regierung angetreten das
staatsbürgerschaftsrecht umfassend zu
reformieren
einbürgerungen zu erleichtern auch mit
einem zweiten platz es wird auch zeit
dass wir endlich anerkennen dass die
menschen unterschiedliche biografien
haben unterschiedliche wurzeln und dass
deswegen also wirklich unbedingt was
beim staatsangehörigkeitsrecht gemacht
werden muss und dazu gehört auch eine
erleichterte erwerb der deutschen
staatsangehörigkeit
ich finde es grundsätzlich richtig dass
man sich für einen start entscheidet
weil man dann ganz anders auch zu den
werten zu der kultur zu dem rechtsstaat
steht als wenn man zwei messer hat
trotzdem sollte man auch zwei pässe
erlauben aber dieses nun unter
bestimmten voraussetzungen sind gegeben
und die sollte man jetzt nicht
aufweichen wer ist wir was typisch
deutsch ein stetiges aushandeln von
zugehörigkeit und ausgrenzung besonders
wenn sich verschiedene identitäten und
wurzeln verwegen einstimmen gegen
vorurteile und diskriminierung die
gesellschaftspolitische atmosphäre wird
jeden pass mit füßen treten der pass
rettet dich nicht vor dem hass aber der
pass ist in einem land in dem der
respekt und die würde im vordergrund
steht ein großes geschenk die
ausstellung am bhm läuft noch bis januar
über das kleine stück papier des lebens
und überlebens chancen prägt und vieles
ist zwischen schutzschild und wasser
so und jetzt hier bei uns kunde mit den
wichtigsten nachrichten vom sport es war
ein perfekter tag für die deutschen
tennisspielerinnen in rembrücken jule
niemeyer und tatjana maria stehen im
viertelfinale die erst 22 jährige
dortmunderin niemeyer feierte bei ihrem
zweiten grand slam turnier einen
souveränen sieg gegen die britin heather
watson härter kämpfen musste die
erfahrene tatiana maria aus bad saulgau
zwei matchbälle wehrte sie gegen die
lettin ostapenko ab am dienstag treffen
die beiden dann aufeinander im kampf um
das halbfinale
die dritte etappe der tour de france hat
in dänemark der niederländer dylan krone
wegen gewonnen landsmann fabio jacobsen
wurde nach seinem sieg gestern heute
fünfter die beiden verbindet eines der
größten sturz dramen im radsport so
machen ihre torerfolge jetzt
schlagzeilen im gelben trikot fährt am
dienstag der bilder von 8
in der formel 1 hat der spanier carlos
sainz junior beim großen preis von
großbritannien seinen ersten sieg
gefeiert zweiter wurde sergio perez
dritter lewis hamilton überschattet
wurde das rennen von einer
massenkarambolage in runde eins dabei
überschlug sich der wagen des chinesen
huang yue der schließlich im fangzaun
landete so blieb aber unverletzt
und noch ein erfolg im reitsport gerrit
nieberg hat zum abschluss der
turnierwoche in aachen überraschend den
großen preis im springreiten gewonnen
mit seinen westfalen wallach ben elf
jahre alt legte der sohn von
olympiasieger lars nieberg im stechen
den schnellsten und fehlerfreien ritt
hin zweiter wurde scott brash aus
großbritannien
und jetzt wie immer sonntags die frage
was wird wichtig der heute journal
ausblick auf die kommende woche von
scott sternberg
[Musik]
bundeskanzler scholz will am montag
gemeinsam mit arbeitnehmern und
arbeitgebern über lösungen zum umgang
mit der aktuellen preissteigerung
beraten er wolle beide seiten zu einer
konzertierten aktion zusammenrufen um
gegensätzliche interessen in einklang zu
bringen
[Musik]
fachkräftemangel energiewende die folgen
der ukraine krise welchen beitrag kann
das handwerk in diesen zeiten leisten
und welchen die politik die
internationale handwerksmesse ii h m
findet ab mittwoch auf dem messegelände
münchen statt auf der wichtigsten
leistungsschau des deutschen handwerks
widmen sich politik wirtschaft und
handwerksverbände den drängenden fragen
der zeit
in afghanistan bislang die rettung
vieler afghanischer ortskräfte nach dem
abzug der bundeswehr besonders
schutzbedürftig waren personen die zuvor
westliche streitkräfte im land
unterstützt hatten ab donnerstag wird
der bundestag hierzu einen afghanistan
untersuchungsausschuss einsetzen
am freitag treffen sich die
aussenminister der g 20 auf bali dieses
jahr hat indonesien den vorsitz auch der
russische außenminister lawrow wird an
dem treffen teilnehmen
und das wetter in dieser juliwoche wird
überwiegend sommerlich schön morgen gibt
es nur im norden einzelne schauer und
südlich der donau regnet es kräftiger
teils mit gewittern sonst wird es sonnig
bei 20 grad an der nordsee und bis 28
grad am oberrhein dienstag und mittwoch
zeigen sich freundlich es gibt kaum
schauer oder gewitter etwas nasser wird
der donnerstag im norden bei 18 bis 26
grad
und das war unsere welt an diesem
sonntag wir sind auch morgen in der
neuen woche wieder für sie da und zwar
sehr gerne vom gesamten team einen guten
abend und bis morgen
[Musik]